what's up everybody on Nick Scarpino
this is tim gettys we are from kinda
funny calm and today we're gonna take
you through some things you may have
missed in the international trailer for
Star Wars as well as something like a
nine TV spots yeah it's been nine
commercials nine commercials that have
come out there's tons tons of new
imagery little things we may have missed
we're gonna actually go through frame by
frame right now and then take you
through some of them yeah so I got I got
all the the new scenes all the new CEO
my stuff from the teeth the two teaser
trailers or the trailer that we we all
have seen perfect so a lot of its just
alternate versions are things that like
that are slightly different from what
we've already seen right this for
example it extended imagery or maybe
like a close-up shot or some other stuff
that's you know yeah kind of puts puts
the rest of story in con a little bit
more perspective come here you know
we've seen we've seen ray kind of
exploring the the Star Destroyer right
and now this is her kind of like looking
at one of the yeah like one of the
engines of the Star Destroyer right so
she may kind of be going in then of
course that first shot we saw the first
trailer that came out where she say
ziplining don't we see her going in
there to sort of scavenge whatever is in
the exact that might be the exterior
shot for that so here we have a song
that we've seen before but this one got
a little extended look at the ship kind
of flying away right now what's cool
about this as we've seen before the dot
is actually the foot of an 80 80 that
fell on its side I kind of rusted out
and the theory goes that that's kind of
what Ray's using as her home on this
planet of jakku which is not tattoo not
tattooing yeah so you know they'd said
that a long time ago back at start with
celebration this is actually a new
planet called jakku apparently there are
only three types of planets in the Star
Wars universe there's the desert the
forest and then the hoff land and i'll
always be hot exactly course so you know
the shots of the trails you kind of see
that she's like looking at the ship
leave and it's very Luke Skywalker asked
in the beginning of a new hope when he's
just like man when's it gonna be my
chance to get off this planet right like
actually write you something and that's
backed up by the of course the line sir
she's like who lupita nyong'o scared is
like who are you like I'm nobody Yeah
right so here we see her this is a to me
very reminiscent of like the kind of Han
Solo grito exchange le'Bryan me hope the
power just kind of establishes the
character and like what they're capable
of like she's holding her own you know
she's here she's fighting these
characters are very like the kind of
nomadic we're seeing that they're out
that they lived a hard life these guys
aren't used to
like the cushy life right haha they're
out there they're in the middle of the
desert they have to fight for survival
and she's fighting as well yes so we've
seen this shot before any other trailers
where we see the explosion but was the
niners come over instead they start
shooting is what's exploding is the shed
dope ship yeah so I'm assuming they were
planning on using that ship to escape
deploy the plans had been foiled I'm
sure they'll get off somehow spoilers
it's called Star Wars not desert Wars
yes very true going we gotta get to the
store somehow some way so I love this
shot the shot of the shot beautiful now
first off this is a very uh Apocalypse
Now okay in a pop-up snails but yeah
with the Huey's uh coming out of you
know from the sunset and I love the
smell of napalm animal yes exactly so so
you see that interesting it'll be
fascinating if JJ Abrams is like you
know what I want to do is a little
Omashu in my Star Wars film Apocalypse
Now i mean i'm pretty sure it is so
beautiful so this is a shot leading up
to a lot of what we've seen before of
the kind of the raid on jakku way we see
people just get messed up right and we
have the beginning of that and so this
is what we think is you know them on
jakku now destroying this nomadic
culture yes so i'm going to assume that
they're they're here hunting for
Anakin's lightsaber you think so yes oh
that's why i backed up by kylo Ren sort
of like his via or he's like I'm gonna
finish what you start yeah right so you
have to sort of all the classic kind of
Darth Vader schwag Mme so here we see
this guy's first time we actually seen
one of the flame troopers in in motion
in actions brutal several he's doing his
thing and then just explosion with bb-8
because there's more baby 80 newest BB a
man the home he's going to the homing
here's what's crazy idea is you don't
from that from the first couple trailers
you don't get a sense of how big he is
until you actually see him next to a fin
in ray right what you see in and when
they're kind of exiting the tent and
they look over and they see the the TIE
fighters sort of coming into the Sun you
get a sense that he's actually a lot
bigger he's actually probably closer to
the size of r2d2 I think a little ball
like this big oh yeah I mean yeah he's a
probably maybe like two-thirds the size
of our t think saturday oh yeah there's
you yeah okay I was just at Disney left
we saw a long you saw our stuff I there
was bb-8 he was there himself okay I
could
get his autograph the line was too well
yes I doesn't have hands um so hospital
frame design this year this is a shot
that we saw in the san diego comic-con
kind of it wasn't a trailer it was more
of just like a behind-the-scenes look
and like getting people like ready for
Star Wars and we see this and it's a
stormtrooper kind of capturing poe
dameron who was played by Oscar Isaacs
Oscar Isaac um who he's kind of like the
the pilot of the the force awakens
Sharon an integer so the capturing him
but what's interesting is I think that
that's famed we think it's fan inside I
think it's been in this that's the storm
surge a traffic yeah that's kind of
capturing him and bringing it does have
fin sort of silhouette right cuz he's a
little bit wider and it's on the other
shots me especially when they trade off
you can sort of see the difference in
their body shape yeah that may actually
yeah could not be but we'll see um so
here we get a shot that arm this is Finn
definitely you see blood on his issues
was a bloody handprint of the bloody
print of somebody he may have just
witnessed dying and then I made I think
that the in the background there i think
that is kylo Ren without as a helmet on
oh yeah yeah yeah so they're like during
the raid of jakku you feel like we're
gonna actually see Adam driver without
that without the helmet on the first oh
oh definitely i'm thought we've seen
pictures of me behind seeds know what I
wasn't in the trailer oh yeah what do
you in when he's fighting the forest
with a lightsaber we've got and he has
his hair that looks very Anakin
Skywalker very it is for hidden creek
okay okay um so you see the blood here
we saw it in the first trailer don't for
the second answer it was we saw this
with the blood of him taking it off so
i'm assuming that he's seen him sees all
this happened and he's just like I'm I'm
out I'm out like I can I'm gonna Jack
this tie fighter even though I probably
don't know how to pilot and I'm gonzo so
he's probably like a really low-level
grunt hmm and a grunt stormtrooper and
Industry ler in the fin TV spot he has
his own commercial which would put dope
course he does he fireman's throw
something to Manuel I'm not gonna ask
from a 45 second spot I'm not that crazy
but at least 15 yeah I've just [ __ ]
over you do give me this look actually I
was melges zealander spot was good i was
good is about that on his his teaser
kind of starts off with him talking he's
just like you know I've seen things
right you know I know I don't want a
part of this this is bad and so this is
kind of him
after the blood and all that being like
I'm out so he takes the TIE fighter
advances we've seen the other trailers
the TIE fighter kind of like it's shot
like crashes down on the coup and me
worry about the first image we ever saw
of Star Wars which was the desert and
then him popping up it up like sweating
like I gotta get away from this so this
is really cool you know we know that her
name's ray we know that his name is Finn
but these are the fur this is the first
time that we've actually heard them say
that it talk to each other they top each
others here yes seemingly one of the
first times they've come together but
looks like they're on the bridge of the
line foul yes so I'm assuming that you
know all the desert than fighting and
all the stuff that we've been seeing
they don't know each other they just
kind of like okay yeah this is been
catching a breath during the Millennium
Falcon my guess is when he crash-lands
where he finds himself on that planet he
fine it's near the town that she's in
that's what kind of gets her yes yes so
here we have a shot of her piloting the
Millennium Falcon I look is awesome I
love very very awesome of course you see
sort of you know in later images that
she may not know exactly how to pilot ah
a ship as robust as the Millennium
Falcon what she's trying she's trying
she's definitely going it she's giving
it all and then we got here another nice
nod to new hold of it we got Finn on the
turret of the Millennium Falcon very
don't get cocky yet exactly 11 and then
so we've seen a lot of the shots of the
morning talking flying and doing all
these evasive maneuvers and kind of
barrel rolling and stuff and here BB
eights just kind of rolling around and
like flying through hello let's go I
want a bb8 so badly can we turn Kevin
into BB it we can try it's not gonna be
too hard I've been a little paint
morning so here we got a London felt
kind of flying through the trees in this
shot looks awesome i cannot wait like
see this kind of play out right um and
then more man but these are just you
know get the shot rapes this just looks
like Star Wars you know I reminiscent of
sort of the last sequence from a new
hope they're getting their awards
probably not the same planet but doesn't
this so this might be Gavin you think
she's the planet from uh um from neo
from the end of a new hope for the rebel
bases and all that that castle with
everyone gets an award except for except
for shooting a boy Chewie yeah today I'm
Shane got disc so over there that castle
is lupita nyong'o character named mas
que nada so we don't know much about her
but she's an alien creature it's gonna
be like CG and stuff and I will see
we'll see what all this goes but we saw
in the earlier trailer that shot up like
all of them kind of walking into the
castle yeah with those a nurse or yeah
down for hanging so so we'll see what's
up with that if you read the comics you
know that Poe dameron's parents are from
you haven't so there is there is some
stuff going on here where maybe this
might be yeah the architecture looks
similar gives me another place that they
fooled me before man then for like three
months I was like swearing by tattooing
I was like it's Tatooine it's got to be
and they showed the one son and I was
like Dom it's not a do anything got me
so here's so we see we see the ship and
it's very iconic star wars but this this
is the one that makes me go oh yeah
seeing shots like this and Star Wars
make me have it because this is very
there's a lot of there's been a lot of
can work in here that's that's very JJ
Abrams yet right and you like into this
earlier we're talking about these shots
you're like this is like the GoPro sure
yes a good go for all the way out on the
wing of an x-wing and it's great you
know that's it's very even some of the
imagery that we saw earlier we're like
when they're you know in some of the
other trailers where they're coming out
of the tent you get the chakra first
shot of their perspective you don't
normally see a lot of that camera work
in a Star Wars film it's usually very
much like just kind of witnessing the
characters from from you know standing
the sidelines but we're actually seeing
it's a lot more intimate yeah that's
very very reminiscent of JJ style a very
very gone as you can see those x-wings
half of the blue stripe on this blue
team ok no my favorite of the teams um
so yeah so here we go we got Oscar
Isaacs character Poe Dameron kind of
piloting in the classic Star Wars
cockpit view and you see the rest of the
blue team here like his we don't know
her name yet but what one of his
teammate is it cool a cool signature on
her helmet them like I like that symbol
yeah and then we got this dude right
here who looks a lot like Lando's
co-pilot yeah from Return of the Jedi
you know do we feel like it's him uh it
could be him it could be a descendant of
him or just someone just the one of his
races race we chose like but i'll bring
it cool i'll i would be if they're like
we don't we need one more pilot for blue
squadron lyneham just feels like I'm
here I got you guys good i piloted the
copilot the million fog and I'm ready to
step up hmm so we've seen a lot of shots
of them kind of flying over the lake of
that planet that we were earlier saying
is you haven't even apply not be haven't
but this looks kind of like they're
going through the hyperspace because the
new hypertension JJ Abrams irse
hyperspace we're getting that you get
the normal white lines and you go
through this like blue he's mad he's got
to make it hissed together you gotta go
for blue team I was I was thinking when
I first saw that shot that potentially
they were
the ice planet that we're going to see
later in in the later images with a baby
that's maybe potentially yeah so here oh
my god a gorgeous can you get more star
wars in this k then this is like a Last
Supper too yeah i mean Leia looks like
Jesus just sitting in the middle of da
I've got all the Bolivar disciples
around her well what's cool this is you
know you know back in there and return
the Jedi we had Mon Mothma kind of like
planet after the new hope we had this
very similar-looking thing and now we
have Princess Leia now generally kind of
planning this whole thing we got our boy
on over there a bunch of other stuff and
c3po is that I'm relax on the back it
looks like apple or a person of Akbar's
again species yeah we don't know so we
got c-3po with his red arm yeah what's
going on with the right arm don't know
how it happened is that one everyone
else but there is a comic series that is
coming out this month that explains how
his he lost his armor got red I don't
know maybe Chewie put it back together
the wrong way we don't know um and then
so here's another shot where we see
princess later general Leia in the back
with poe dameron and c3po with his red
arm like a boss and then just more
clouds of characters I like his little
scarf yeah like this is the fun thing
that they've added like all these little
flares the update at the costumes and
things like that we're not seeing quite
like the stereotypical like boot and and
really skinny pant like he's got a
little more style here yeah he's a
little older he's dressing like an older
gentleman with a little scarf a little
more sophistication I love that's cold
you still got the sort of like priests
like you know collar line which is cool
but you know love it and his hairs a
little long so speaking of Han Solo here
here we got a shot that this on with
that iconic heavy black so he has his
pasta roller and this shot is so
reminiscent of them breaking out Leia
from from a new hope the Death Star yep
and I'm assuming here they're breaking
program ran out you can see Finn wearing
Poe dameron's jacket from earlier okay
so and then chuys over there kind of
setting some some charges about to blow
some stuff up yeah she only has two
things that he does he's really good pal
and he blow stuff up yeah yeah he does
it well so here Han Solo in the trailers
like you ready to do this and then fins
like hell no no yeah you can already you
can already tell you're gonna like John
wait I got a lot yeah because he's very
much the character that's like I'm just
trying to survive i'm just trying to get
away from all this and I'm sucked back
in and I have he
reluctant hero I mean I think that
Finn's gonna be kind of the character
that they want us to relate to he's
going to be the Luke of the of the movie
where you know you kind of grow with him
but instead of being a farm boy kinda
turns into a stuff he's actually
low-level grunt of the Empire right or
the new order your arm he's done some
stuff for the first order first order
the first order right where he's uh kind
of like no I'm low-level guy but I'm
taking this and this is wrong and I know
it's wrong I think that's really cool
kind of twist because we haven't seen
the personalities of the stormtroopers
in the films hmm so I mean and then
that's that's the fun part is I'm
definitely gonna relate to him because
I'm used to being the character that has
no idea what's going on yeah most of the
time uh-huh and just just kind of goes
with it I'm like today I'm like the old
man of the group yeah just I'm here for
the ride man just along for the ride all
right so then this is chewy kind of
detonating the charge now we saw we're
about to see we've seen before we've
seen this one in multiple trailers other
thing blowing up I think chuys blowing
up like you think I charge is blowing
this up now this where they are right
now I think it's the command center um
on that icy planet right that we've
we've been seeing a lot now this shot
here we see we've seen the alternate
angle of this no more where we can look
at all the bad guys just kind of
chilling with like the whole armies and
stuff now we see Captain phasma right
played by Gwendoline Christie right from
Game of Thrones um who is gonna be so
awesome now ya can always she's amazing
she's amazing got a couple of flame
troopers just chillin there and then
kylo Ren's there now the thing is who is
the general right like the guy was
leading all of this stuff so when you
know a new hope and we had general
Tarkin now it's like who's this guy and
we know that Andy Serkis is playing a
character he's playing snoc general US
stocks know how we haven't seen we don't
really know too much about him so I'm
assuming that the he's kind of like
behind this whole endeavor we also see
this amazing shot yeah it is very very
very I mean either they pulled a lot of
the imagery from like from like not CS
yes style image on this world war two
and this is very much that and raising
that raising their hands and sort of a
solute and what schools you see all that
you see the kind of dichotomy between
the
you know the dudes and the stormtroopers
and then also you see all the different
types of stormtroopers like if you look
like you see the pyro ones there's three
different types there right yeah and the
guys normal ones and I don't know what
the ones are with the three kind of
rectangles on their their chests maybe
they're more like heavy you say luckily
maybe are they look a little bit like
the speeder troopers from Return of the
Jedi like that maybe they don't not the
same not in the Hellmouth speeders yeah
how does that vein kind of you know the
ribs or the magazine clips or whatever
they whatever they are different types I
yeah that's relieving I like the kind of
fleshing out the the troops and stuff
and it is it just makes you guys know I
don't and here's why cuz I have to buy
all the point okay before there was only
like two there's like three different
troopers before you're like I don't
really need the Imperial Guard we can
put that away I want this so we've seen
this shot before of a snow planet and I
have a theory that there's more to this
than meets the eye okay so on the poster
for Star Wars you very clearly see a
Death Star looking same thing in the
background right right now we know that
that's called the star killer okay and
supposedly it's like there's death star
blows up planets right Starkiller
supposedly blows up solar systems Wow
yeah so escalation where is it gonna be
and it's crazy we haven't seen it in the
trailers at all at all you know an atom
with all this footage we haven't seen it
my theory is that it is anything you
think we have seen it we didn't know we
were saying because I love this image is
here if you look here you kind of see
that trench right what's that remind you
of or a little bit of one of the Death
Star's exactly just a live show that's
so it looks like that and then we've
seen some new images here that really
look like the death yeah that looks like
the exterior of the Death Star so I kind
of like that though and I can only hope
that at some point someone goes that's
no planet that'll be amazing although
that might be a little too other does it
is it is it definitely is but all men
I'd get the chance not a man that's no
moon so we've seen we've seen this
lightsaber in many different formats
write this this is the hot new commodity
this is everything that everyone's like
when we first saw this it was like you
just took it up to the second level okay
does not only does it have not only is
it red very reminiscent of Darth Vader
of course he's gotta replace everything
zze love
Peter Berg go he's gotta just take it up
a notch yeah with the hilly takes it up
another notch here right and he's kind
of like pointed it at a great day here
in a lot of the trailers we heard Lupita
nyong'o's character in the TV spots they
were talking here she's talking about
like i like i know your eyes I've seen
those eyes for many years I've seen
different people grow up and she's gotta
be different people they I did she's
seen people and then had them up kids
and all this stuff right with the same
sort of heroic look the same sort of
like courage yeah II in each Pearson's
eyes that she has seen so I think
there's people I I have a theory that
I've you know explained many times over
over the course Lana hiding Star Wars is
that she is Han Solo's daughter and that
kylo Ren is her brother also han solo's
for some interesting yeah so this is a
very interesting little family dynamic
which stores is all aban I kind of hope
they don't do that though I kind of hope
she is just another person that is sort
of in touch with the force ah because it
would be a little hard for me to believe
that Han Solo had a kid and potentially
maybe with Leia especially if she's got
forced well I would have to be have to
be and they don't know that that kids
late like they don't know where their
kids are again it's a little too much
like I don't know that JJ would actually
go down that road of being like because
that was the biggest flaw with the with
the the newest trilogy was that they
were like we're gonna kind of take these
kids away from Darth Vader and what he
just forgot about him yeah i know they
sort of lied and said that the kids had
died like you know they would felt that
i'm not gonna get too far yeah yeah i
mean but even even go there i think that
they'll and like I know those reasons I
mean I think the fact that we haven't
seen Luke yet I think whatever if what
I'm saying turns out to be true they
will explain it and it will make sense
because they're not dumb they won't just
like doing a rule where's the girl
Lawrence casa has not done um going
forward so we see a boy hon in action
that and I yep in the 90s dance may have
it that I nail it like how it helped
things that no why didn't you that we're
actually seeing this like his duties
back to work man you can't you can't
nobody puts Han Solo in a corner no okay
you can't sideline han Solo i'll sell it
was a man of action look at him look at
that bum ya chewies ducking what the
hell's he doing over there trying to get
his hair burnt thought it advisable it
might be dad so you know these next
couple of shots I I put them out of
order of the scenery there in trailer so
Sharon owner anyways but so you kind of
see Han shoot
and then kylo Ren's just like swiping
things away with his life right he's
deflecting I'm not sure the hot shooting
at him he's probably not but it's pretty
cool then we see Han giving ray a blast
blast now this is some father-daughter
moment it does look like a father all
daughter by potentially I love it I just
love it so then she's just like all
right I'll tell you and I'll go to work
yeah absolutely why not so she does so
she is shooting kylo Ren at this point
he is he's just reflected Avis yeah you
it's the first one really seemed you
like fancy lightsaber right and my
favorite thing he like kind of force
pushes away this is the first time that
we've really kind of seen that the
hidden used the fortune away in the
other trailers we kind of saw him do
like we saw him do it like we've seen
him do it Oscar Isaacs character yeah
like we've seen this shot when he turns
uh-huh right but we don't know
necessarily what was emerging why why
he's done it which is cool and then here
we go is the coolest thing I don't know
how I feel about that we've seen in the
spots i don't know how i feel about this
because i don't like the fact that
they've gotten wise since he's the whole
lightsaber okay so here's the thing so
let's go through this and i will we
wanted to rock it so this is kind of
like an assassin's creed esque like
shield thing that he like pops out of
his arm right and then you can see as
John and Finn takes a swipe at him yeah
and like he's we've seen him with the
lightsaber before against kyle rayner he
looks scared and not confident here he
looks confident he he looks like you can
take this guy on because they probably
had the same type of training
potentially yes because he has a
stormtrooper so we we assume we assume
that he knows kind of what this weapon
down or what does the defense weapon
does and how to kind of which we see
here right it's kind of this like shock
blasted things can it looks just like a
shield you know and so it's being used
now my thing is my big question is why
would they have these because you look
at this like oh it's a lightsaber
defense thing that doesn't make sense
when there's not any Jedi tnite it's so
it could just be a shield it could be a
shield or just could be a weapon that
happens to be that happens to put out an
electric charge oh that can repel the
lightsaber yeah that would be my thing
cuz it would be really weird they're
like there's a do the lightsaber arm
everyone with an anti lightsaber weapon
you know it's like I mean well that does
things like there's no seasons I know
he's not a right
right like we know we don't know that by
assume they do we can assume that based
on the images receive he has not he has
forced mate potentially he is in touch
of the force potentially has a force
inside him like all of us do unifies us
all but he has not been trained by
Master Yoda Oh nor has he been trained
by Master Skywalker yet because God is
bear all of that is very true you're
holding out for Ray being a Jedi I know
you are Tom I know you are she's gonna
head but like why can't you should be
happy with her being anyone I don't
understand it she's new hon it's dope
but she's Leia's daughter Nick she's
Hans daughter too okay yeah Tim she's
Hans daughter exactly how come every
time she listen to good she's your
daughter whenever she does something bad
she's Hans daughter gever think about
that well there you have it there's all
all nine TV spots and the plus the
international trip will icing on the
cake for you if you're watching this and
we missed something please let us know
in the comments below and also please
share this with your friends because
let's be honest we're all crazy about
Star Wars and so are they you can find
Tim at Tim gettys on Twitter you can
find me at Nick underscore scarpino on
Twitter let us know if you like this
video then thanks much for watching yeah
see